[Música]
[Aplausos]
muchas gracias como bien me presentaban
mi nombre en creixell trabajo como
profesor de ingeniería telemática en la
universidad técnica federico santa maría
una carrera que se especializa en la
integración de telecomunicaciones
electrónicas y software y van a ver mi
presentación tiene mucho que ver de eso
y además soy investigador en el centro
científico tecnológico al paraíso un
centro que se dedica a la investigación
en física de partículas y parte de
nuestro trabajo ahí es integrar nuevas
tecnologías y tratar de incorporarlas en
la sociedad en la industria de la
sociedad general
me preguntaron la célula charlas sobre
la ciudad del mañana y fue lo primero
sensación fue como
porque la ciudad es donde vivimos
muy pocos temas donde hay tamaña
transversalidad de conceptos y de cosas
ocurriendo en la sociedad
y la ciudad de la ciudad ha crecido con
la humanidad desde los inicios de la
civilización junto con la tecnología
también por lo tanto para enfocar
y que voy a hablar en esta presentación
me voy a concentrar en tres temas que es
energía transporte y medioambiente
qué son tres temas que están en la
ciudad y si los podemos resolver en la
ciudad los podemos resolver en el mundo
y para partir quisiera explicar un
concepto que es de la finalización
normalmente cuando nuestra área en el
área tecnología hacemos una predicción
de qué es lo que va a ocurrir en el
futuro
no andamos ni cerca normalmente nos
equivocamos las predicciones que dicen
falta mucho tiempo para que ocurra esto
ocurre antes las predicciones cuando
dices esto ocurren muy pronto no ocurre
nunca podemos ver por ejemplo el caso de
la película volver al futuro se acuerdan
que el 2015 era el día de el año de la
película sobre el futuro bueno aún no
tenemos autos que huelen
para hay algunas cosas que sí se parecen
en esa predicción
entonces para poder predecir
lo que yo quiero hacer en realidad es
ver procesos que están ocurriendo y los
procesos que están ocurriendo son
procesos que quiero llamar que muchos
ustedes están familiarizados que son de
finalización es decir como en redes
sociales alguien tomó una foto pone una
frase de algún famoso de algún político
etcétera y la gente encuentra gracioso o
lo encuentra ingenioso sólo muestra
odios o lo que sea y se lo comparte a
sus amigos y sus amigos a sus amigos y
eso después recorre todo el mundo eso es
lo que el fenómeno finalización
que está representado en el dibujito ahí
y en esta idea yo quiero hablarle para
que eso ocurra en tecnología tiene que
pasar de que primero tiene que aportar
un valor concreto claro
porque la tecnología de por sí no es
importante
lo importante es el valor que nos
entrega la tecnología
y en el caso de medio ambiente
yo quiero hablar de una tecnología
que este es positivo que está aquí
este dispositivo que está acá cuesta
tres dólares
en chile
cuesta tres dólares yo lo puedo conectar
sensores y si ustedes se fijan
aquí tiene la antena
es decir se puede comunicar de forma
inalámbrica
tiene 4 megas de memoria y en estos
ojitos que está acá
yo le puede conectar sensores
pensemos en quintero
pensemos en puchuncaví
qué podríamos hacer con esto es hacer
y estaciones de medición de calidad del
aire extremadamente baratas que
significa barato que las podemos
realizar que podemos poner muchas y las
podemos poner monitoreando en tiempo
real
porque cuál es el sistema de monitoreo
que tenemos actualmente y quintero
el número intoxicado en urgencia
cierto
yo que vengo al monte la tecnología esto
es indignante porque podemos hacerlo
mucho mejor como sociedad
qué hacemos nosotros en el centro de
investigación el año pasado
con la s m que es la superintendencia mi
ambiente
desarrollamos 30 de estas estaciones
para medir la calidad del aire las
integramos las programamos las
construimos y se las pasamos a la smg
para medir ciertas variables de la
calidad del aire que era el material
particulado fino la temperatura y la
humedad la gente de la 'semana estaba
interesada en medir en probar cuatro
marcas de sensores baratos y por qué
están interesado en probarlo porque los
sensores uno tiene que cuestionarse
bueno este sensor está midiendo bien
corresponde exactamente la lectura del
sensor a lo que está pasando en el aire
o me está mintiendo entonces pusimos
estas estaciones de medición cerca de
las estaciones formales que tiene en
santiago en cada una de las comunas una
por comuna una por comuna
para poder comparar nuestro desarrollo y
estos sensores con la medición
que creemos correcta que es la de ellos
el resultado y ayto esto cada cinco
minutos entregando información en tiempo
real de las mediciones
una de las marcas de los sensores de
bajo precio ha funcionado muy bien
en el caso volviendo al caso quintero
ahí habría que probar qué tipo de
sensores son los necesarios pues son
gases me parece más complicado pero
bueno lo podemos hacer pues seguro que
sí
eso es un ejemplo de cómo la tecnología
aporta valor
es útil y si es barata para estar en
todas partes
me paso a la energía
la energía es es súper importante como
para poder desarrollar la actividad
económica para movernos para en fin la
usamos para todo
es un concepto extremadamente importante
y que lo que está ocurriendo el sector
energético nosotros tenemos en chile un
potencial fotovoltaico enorme en el
norte de chile tenemos entiendo las
mejores condiciones mundiales para la
generación de energía solar ya sea
fotovoltaica o de otra naturaleza
y la tecnología está permitiendo que
podamos incluir estos estos paneles
en nuestras casas
los vehículos están cambiando
la nueva tendencia es que ahora son
eléctricos o van a ser eléctrico varias
marcas están anunciando volvo demente
que en un par de años más no va a
fabricar más vehículos de combustión
interna para ser solo eléctricos toyota
ha hecho anuncios similares etcétera no
es solo tesla de eeuu que el tesla más
barato hasta el último modelo era 80 mil
dólares
lo cual significa que yo no voy a tener
nunca un tesla
quizá
o sea no
la silla
pero cuando nissan cuando toyota cuando
otras marcas que producen vehículos que
son vehículos de trabajo y lo normal es
que ustedes puede tener que puedo tener
eléctricos ya es un cambio importante y
que significa entonces si tenemos
generación fotovoltaica en la casa
eólica también puede ser en casa pienso
por ejemplo las casas de él
en playa ancha
siempre ancha y el viento
tendría la energía de noche
tendremos generación en la casa
pero además tendríamos almacenamiento
donde la batería de auto
en la batería de los buses
donde se guardan los buses y esa energía
que está almacenada
pues yo podría usarla venderla cuando no
lo necesito
por qué no
esta figura que está aquí muestra el
ejemplo de cómo lo que estoy diciendo se
está finalizando
esto es un estudio dice una empresa en
eeuu que se dedica a recopilar datos
relacionados datos relacionado energía y
eso iba a ser big data con eso con esa
información destacan algunas
conclusiones
este resultado acá tomaron durante 10
años 215 mil hogares y empezaron a tomar
una serie de variables para que para
poder determinar cuál es la probabilidad
de que esa casa
ponga paneles solares y ahora se
preguntarán por qué es importante
porque de eso se trata bonito bueno
además la cosa imagen pero porque es
importante porque para la empresa
eléctrica que quiere distribuir
tiene que comprar o sea tiene que
entregar energía en un sentido y desde
el abonado domiciliario tiene que
recibir por lo tanto mi infraestructura
tiene que estar preparada para poder
recibir energía y eso significa porque
tradicionalmente el voltaje a medida que
yo me acerco al cliente va decayendo y
eso está diseñado así pero cuando tengo
generación en el punto extremo eso no
ocurre así y muchas veces tengo que
levantar las líneas de tensión para
poder conducir las de sitios culturales
y esa inversión es cara y ahí es en este
estudio para saber dónde lo que
encontraron e interesante
fundamentó un poco lo que estoy diciendo
y es que de todas las
variables de entrada que era la primera
el ingreso 1 para poner paneles solar en
la casa hay que tener una casa sea
mediando el barrio eso puede ser caro
cierto nivel de ingresos
el segundo factor era dentro las
variables era si hay cerca en mi barrio
gente con paneles solares
y después venía una cantidad enorme de
variables para poder determinar esto que
eran por ejemplo tiene inversión en
fondos mutuos tiene perros no tienen
perro les gusta la actividad en aire
libre etcétera para tratar de
caracterizar qué tipo de gente de ahí y
estimar la probabilidad de si va a poner
paneles solares el resultado
es que la variable que más influye no es
el ingreso
no es cuánto gana la persona o la
familia
la variable más importante es si mi
vecino puso
o sea como un meme o sea 100 puso porque
yo no
y ese y en la segunda variable que
explica esto en el ingreso pero bastante
por debajo en el poder de predicción
y si más veces nos ponían esto aumenta
por lo tanto se está realizando un
fenómeno exponencial
yo freno exponencial
la señal es esta semana en una
presentación de smart grid
que organizamos con chilquinta huawei
y al parecer por la gente de las
empresas eléctricas lo que está diciendo
era un poco
y por qué no porque el medio
usted tiene los datos no tiene la
información cierta la información de las
conclusiones no pueden tomar decisiones
este el escenario está ahora que se ve
que el gobierno está promoviendo en las
viviendas sociales poner paneles solares
que mucha gente dice esto es ridículo si
las van a poner a mediados agua van a
poner que cuesta 500 mil pesos un equipo
que el puro inversor cuesta un millón de
pesos
bueno puede ser que haya crítica
razonable pero por otro lado yo creo que
están haciendo lo correcto
el gobierno está con esa política
proponiendo la innovación propiciando la
y le está poniendo en jaque a las
empresas eléctricas en esos sectores
después vendrá la clase media y la clase
acomodada qué sé yo pero vamos a poner
en este escenario donde tengo a otra
generación
nuestra legislación solamente yo le
puedo vender a la empresa que wii
yo no puedo poner un enchufe inteligente
yo vengo la tecnología y estas cosas me
emocionan entonces dónde frustran
digamos o me irrita no me indignan como
acaso y entero
que me gustaría hacerlo podemos tener un
enchufe inteligente afuera con un
aparato como éste que además de los
estudiantes que tienen el talento el
tiempo y lohana cerillo
yo voy a salir la foto no está gastada
los estudiantes que estarán por ahí
saben que yo no sé si aciertan
bueno
qué es lo que gustaría poner hecho fe
inteligente con una aplicación y que la
aplicación de forma automática negocie
con alguien de un auto eléctrico el
precio
de la energía que yo les voy a vender
y no tengo y no se meta nadie porque una
cuestión de privado
actualmente sólo se puede hacer
yo no puedo hacer eso aunque mi energía
en mi casa en mi chufi es el auto de la
otra persona etcétera está de acuerdo
estamos de acuerdo para la regulación
dice no tenemos hacer eso
es ahí cuando uno empieza así
a llorar
déjame sanar
entonces
así como el gobierno por una parte
puede utilizar las políticas públicas
para promover la innovación para
propiciar la también la puedes matar en
otras condiciones
hay varias ejemplos andaba por las ramas
en varios ejemplos en los que la
legislación en chile ha sido bien era
por ejemplo en neutralidad la red fue lo
primero en el mundo
y las doscientas millas marítimas de
exclusiva económica sabían ustedes que
esas nuevas propuestas chilenas
se puede ser innovador incluso
legislando
qué otros está pasando en nuestra
universidad por ejemplo acá a instalar
un mega watt de energía fotovoltaica en
los techos porque tenemos muchos techos
y eso es una iniciativa que es pionera
en sudamérica y una universidad tenga
tal capacidad de generación por lo tanto
los que somos clientes libres me refiero
a organizaciones que tienen mucho
consumo podemos escoger quién nos vende
la energía y no estamos obligados a la
empresa a distribuir a una clínica un
hospital una fábrica de una universidad
puedes quién les compra con esto
nosotros estamos reduciendo el costo
incluso vendiendo si nos sobra
y nuestra digamos huella de carbono
mucho más reducida
este un ejemplo en eeuu donde 50 casas
50 casas se usan de acuerdo con auto
generación y ellos intercambian energía
utilizando block chain básicamente lo
que hace esta esta plataforma es que se
puede transar energía hacer subasta
energía quien compra quien vende de
forma automática y segura
y todos pueden y transparente cosas a lo
que está pasando
eso está pasando en un edificio puede
ocurrir eso por ejemplo
poner un edificio normalmente tiene un
mayor y remarcadores y la línea interna
es privada y nuestra regulación
afortunadamente ahí no se puede meter y
que energía pero puedo venderla que
tengo almacenamiento
valparaíso
a nuestro medio del país
el tercer problema de realización un
poco negativo y tema el transporte
en chile tenía un millón de autos el
pasamos a 7 millones
actualmente
el año pasado se compraron 390 mil y
algo autos nuevos si yo los pongo
parachoques con parachoques llegó más
allá de quique
solo con auto nuevos sin contar lo que
ya tenemos
o sea tener auto no es la solución para
las ciudades del mañana
la solución del transporte público
la solución del transporte público verde
transporte público eléctrico con la
misma visión de los porteños de hace 150
años donde teníamos 32
a sensores eléctricos los trolebuses el
tren eléctrico
y ahora
estamos volviendo a eso
quizás la solución no esté en el futuro
sino que mirar el pasado y en la visión
de los viejos porteñas
[Música]